[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Io sono Elisabetta
Adami scrittrice di libri per ragazzi ma
i bambini mi chiamano sempre la mamma di
Geronimo Stilton e stasera scoprirete
perché prima di tutto Sono molto felice
di essere qui con voi stasera per
condividere la mia storia una storia che
parla di dolore ma anche di gioia di
sofferenza ma anche di speranza di libri
ma anche di topi e sono grata al Ted per
questo opportunità di raccontarvi
stasera come mi sono salvata la vita
grazie alla fantasia
tanti anni fa scoprì di non poter avere
figli e per me fu un momento molto
difficile
sentivo nel cuore un dolore tremendo
perché io desideravo veramente diventare
mamma però decisi che la vita doveva
andare avanti e che io non potevo non
dovevo affondare con miserarmi e
sprofondare nel mio dolore
e decise che avrei reagito per ritrovare
la fiducia nella vita per questo vi
racconto questa storia stasera e
cominciai a cercare un altro modo di
esprimere il mio istinto materno lo
stesso amore ma in un altro modo per
essere vicina ai bambini
era l'epoca di Patch Adams il medico
americano che si vestiva da clown si
metteva quel naso rosso e da clown per
rallegrare i bambini in corsia in
ospedale
il suo esempio mi ispirò e io pensai non
so fare il clown però che cosa so fare
bene so raccontare storie per ragazzi
sono in un certo senso
un'esperta di fantasia e allora proverò
a scrivere delle storie per rallegrare i
ragazzi e cercare di aiutarli a guarire
prima e meglio così decisi che avrei
inventato delle storie speciali che
fossero umoristiche per divertire i
bambini
avventurose per tener Viva la loro
attenzione ma soprattutto che avessero
anche
tanti tanti tanti tanti tanti valori
etici
valori come amicizie e amore
gentilezza e solidarietà
e rispetto per la natura ma soprattutto
speranza e fiducia nel futuro
fu così proprio così che nacque Geronimo
Stilton un topo intellettuale perché
dirige L'Eco del roditore e scrive tanti
libri Tra l'altro tutti ispirati a
esperienze vere che ho dovuto fare io
per lui perché le potesse raccontare nei
suoi libri Quindi un topo intellettuale
ma anche buffo pasticcione
tenero e timido un po' come me un topo
che in un certo senso è un antieroe
perché non ha paura di sbagliare non ha
paura di cadere Perché sa rialzarsi una
volta di più forse anche per questo I
bambini lo amano tanto perché si
riconoscono nelle sue debolezze che lui
non ha mai paura di ammettere
un topo che sa rialzarsi con fiducia e
fantasia proprio come è successo a me e
come può succedere a tutti noi
Geronimo nacque dal mio cuore per
arrivare al cuore di quei bambini e
donare loro un sorriso in un momento
difficile della loro vita e a poco a
poco successe un piccolo grande miracolo
grazie a quello scambio d'amore anche il
mio cuore
iniziò a guarire e poco alla volta io
ritrovai la fiducia nella vita
quando ricominciai a raccontare quelle
prime storie mi accorsi che i bambini
ridevano alle sue disavventure che
assomigliavano un po' a quelle di
Paperino Però un giorno un bambino mi
chiese preoccupato Sì sì mi diverto ma
c'è un lieto fine è vero
e fu allora che mi resi conto che in
realtà lui mi stava chiedendo ci sarà un
lieto fine anche alla mia storia
personale
e intuii che quei bambini malati in un
momento difficile della loro vita
ma anch'io
stavamo in realtà cercando insieme di
trovare la speranza la fiducia nel
futuro
una cosa di cui noi avevamo veramente
tanto bisogno ma di cui tutti noi
abbiamo sempre bisogno tutti noi che
siamo qui oggi
in questo momento così particolare per
l'umanità c'è ancora più bisogno di
speranza e di fiducia nel futuro di
condivisione di amore di credere nella
pace
e questa è una cosa che solo insieme si
può fare Dobbiamo ricordarci che tutto è
sempre possibile se lo vogliamo e se
tutti insieme troviamo il modo di
collaborare e che davvero c'è sempre una
soluzione ogni problema Basta che
riusciamo a trovarla insieme Questa è
una cosa che Geronimo spiega sempre
ragazzi perché li rende più forti
forse l'avrete già capito io e Geronimo
ci assomigliamo molto moltissimo perché
i confini tra realtà e fantasia per noi
scrittori sono molto sottili per esempio
io e lui condividiamo oltre che l'amore
per la scrittura l'amore per la lettura
che è un valore che noi cerchiamo sempre
di trasmettere ai ragazzi ma anche la
passione per i viaggi perché tutti i
libri che abbiamo scritto insieme io e
il topo sono ispirati a esperienze
realmente vissute
Per esempio io ho scalato il
Kilimangiaro Anche se come Geronimo
soffro di vertigini
ho corso una maratona di New York ma
anche una del deserto del Sahara e tanti
credono che io abbia un fisico
eccezionale non è così proprio come
Geronimo non sono per niente atletica
Però quando
ci sono da fare delle sfide impossibili
perché io adoro le sfide mi organizzo
con degli amici facciamo una squadra
cerchiamo di aiutarci a vicenda e ci
rendiamo sempre conto che insieme anche
l'impossibile diventa possibile
Ho esplorato la natura di tanti paesi
del mondo come le praterie del Nord
America dove ho incontrato i nativi
americani e da loro ho imparato l'amore
per la natura e ho provato l'emozione di
stringere tra le braccia un autentico
cucciolo di lupo
ho visitato le mitiche del Nepal dove le
montagne sembrano toccare il cielo la
straordinaria Isola di Zanzibar dove
vivono tartarughe giganti e farfalle
variopinte il parco naturale di zanga
Sanga in Africa dove ho dovuto
attraversare un fiume piedi nudi e io ho
visto da vicino Gli elefanti E ho
scoperto come spesso racconto i bambini
che gli elefanti prima di vederli li
senti arrivare perché il terreno trema e
si sente l'odore di elefante che sa di
foglie bagnate di terra sa proprio di
selvatico bambini adorano questi
particolari
sempre prendendo appunti sul mio
taccuino o sul mio computer portatile
per non perdere neanche un dettaglio di
quella esperienza ma soprattutto girando
il mondo Ho visto quanti bambini hanno
bisogno del nostro amore e quanto noi
possiamo fare per loro
e per aiutarli a costruire un futuro
felice perché tutti i bambini hanno
diritto alla felicità i bambini hanno
bisogno di noi di amore non solo di un
aiuto pratico
in questi anni grazie a Stilton ho
trovato il mio lieto fine e oggi il mio
sogno è diventato realtà perché sono
diventata la mamma di milioni di bambini
in tutto il mondo Tutti quelli che hanno
letto i miei libri ma non mi sono
fermata lui al topo tanti scrittori dopo
un successo Hanno paura di rischiare e
scrivere qualcosa di nuovo io no ho
deciso di avere fiducia nella mia
fantasia e poi chiamo molto gli animali
continua a scrivere tanti altri libri
tutti con voce di animali per esempio
delle storie per i più piccoli le storie
degli orsetti Billo e Villa ma anche
Così parlò lupo blu un'avventura senza
tempo nella natura dedicata a piccoli e
grandi questo libro per me significa
molto perché io sono stata adottata anni
fa dalla tribù dei Cherokee una tribù di
nativi americani proprio nel clan allo
sviluppo mi adottarono perché mi dissero
che gli storyteller erano un valore
particolare per loro perché aiutano i
ragazzi con le loro storie a imparare i
valori della vita crescere meglio e mi
diedero il nome di ustie Wyatt Che vuol
dire piccolo lupo queste manfreder
l'anziana Cherokee che mi adottò e che
collaborava con le nazioni unite in
operazioni umanitarie ed era anche una
grande poetessa per scrivere questo lupo
visto lupi anche molto da vicino in un
parco nazionale in Abruzzo
Oggi vi ho raccontato la mia storia di
scrittrice per incoraggiarvi ad avere
sempre fiducia in un lieto fine perché
un lieto fine è sempre possibile Se
riusciamo prima di tutto a immaginarlo
con la fantasia che è uno strumento
potentissimo per guardar la vita con
occhi diversi trovare soluzioni nuove e
Sciogliere lo stress in una risata con
gli amici l'umorismo importante ci può
salvare non subendo gli eventi ma
trasformando la sofferenza in energia
positiva
Come in una fantastica Alchimia con una
bacchetta magica la realtà che ci
circonda per veder le cose non come sono
ma come potrebbero essere
impariamo a sognare un futuro migliore
con fantasia crediamo che sia possibile
realizzarlo con fiducia e impegniamoci a
realizzarlo con pazienza e tenacia
soprattutto con l'aiuto degli altri e
aiutando gli altri facendo rete facendo
squadra come noi oggi e siamo qui
insieme per parlare di cose belle buone
perché solo insieme ci può essere la
vera felicità
da quando ho scoperto di non poter figli
la mia vita è cambiata e grazie ai libri
che ho scritto ho potuto aprire la
fondazione Stilton per aiutare i bambini
in Italia del mondo in progetti di
salute e istruzione chiudendo un cerchio
ideale con i bambini dell'ospedale Dove
nacque Stilton posso dire di aver
ricevuto tanto dalla vita per questo mi
impegno ogni giorno per restituire
questo dono meraviglioso la possibilità
attraverso i miei libri di parlare ai
cuori di tutti i miei lettori per
ricordare a tutti l'importanza di volare
sulle ali della Fantasia senza rendersi
mai perché i sogni si possono avverare
se noi crediamo abbastanza con fiducia
ma soprattutto tutti insieme come noi
oggi
Grazie di aver ascoltato la mia storia e
come direbbe Stilton formaggiosi Saluti
a tutti Vi vogliamo bene
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]